hey guys I'm Ryan right hey I'm Jerry
today we're gonna check out the third
trailer darn train for a movie that's
having difficulty getting a home really
wide release the green inferno even
Ferno the new picture from Eli Roth one
of the best directors of all time slash
best actors he is so good at everything
he does let's watch this a Barrett
violence and torture grizzly deserving
images
what's Universal
[Music]
a blue house has picked it up over 100
dirtiness
the room is dangerous we can't just go
invade a country because they're doing
something that we think is immoral hey
you know I just think I should be doing
something about the rainforest yeah make
a difference no movie that involves a
plane that looks like that everyone
hands up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why are they doing this
[Music]
you know what this is you know what
they're doing to us
[Music]
good tagline no good deed goes
unpunished no uh fear will eat you alive
oh man I go on sir Netcom a lot and I'm
always looking at these lists of most
disturbing films of all time it always
deals with like [ __ ] like this you know
especially cannibalism I heard Campbell
owns a big team but you know what's
surprising I would I'm wrong Tomatoes
recently this has like over 60% does it
really yeah which is really shocking
because it's an Eli Roth film be like
the subject matter it isn't like you've
seen its radar for all these like crazy
things and people are actually liking
the film well I mean there are a lot of
notable cannibal movies in the pantheon
of horror cinema I'm a little surprised
just because like I've heard such mixed
things about this from the early
screenings like I know people have seen
who really hated it and thought it was
really uninspired and I know some people
who thought it was pretty good so I'm
very curious about this movie you know
me too and I mean cannibal movies it
seems like ever since you know your
Cannibal Holocaust and stuff they're
always shot with a certain element for
realism there's a mood in a tone that
that I do appreciate about this kind of
thing and I hope you can translate that
well yeah because eli roth movies tend
to have bitchin trailers then you watch
his films and they tend to like just
have a really cheesy over-the-top acting
it moves at a weird pace that's kind of
a little too fast like well he has sort
of a bro a sense of humor so yeah that
can kind of hold the film down you know
totally totally
so I'm curious though I would love to
see a good cannibal movie you know and I
mean it's like it's such a hard shun row
to do now just cuz who's gonna pay for
it yeah this looks hard to sit through
like I hate I don't want to watch it
because it looks like it would be very
difficult to watch yeah you know like
Eli Roth is not known to hold back yeah
you know he definitely likes to make you
squirm yeah and
as I remember I saw a hostel like
opening night that was so many years ago
yeah so opening I an and I was the big
thing that helped hostel cell was the
fact that Tarantino was like presented
or something but because I don't know
how those two became like best buds
maybe he just saw cabin fever II was
like this gas yeah we're gonna be
friends and that's something I do enjoy
about Eli Roth is like he tends to pick
these genres that are barring hostile
cuz torture torture movies were really
big for a minute like he usually picks
these genres that are a little more off
the beaten path nowadays cuz like having
fever is like flesh-eating virus movie
and this is a cannibal movie and these
are just art the horror mainstream so I
appreciate when he does stuff like this
I appreciate that he goes for different
genres of horror I mean they usually
involves some kind of human torture in
some fashion
yeah human cruelty yeah was that woman
also the woman and a trailer for
knock-knock which oh the woman oh oh you
mean you mean the young not sorry you
said the woman and I immediately thought
of like the woman with her face painted
and like the beads in her nose and I was
like no oh yeah the main character ah
maybe knock-knock I don't know the movie
is a really interesting theme of like an
interesting consequence theme of going
out there I think they're like students
or whatever and they're trying to go
preserve the rainforest because people
are tearing it down that's why they had
that shot of the dude in the backhoe
like Western civilization keeps tearing
down the rainforest but what was her dad
telling her about like how you're
stepping in just because you can't just
because like you know even though it's
[ __ ] up that the people down there are
destroying the rainforest you can't just
go because I think the point is they go
to do this rain forest preservation
thing plain never happen upon this try
like the tribe is a completely
unexpected part of this okay okay
because that's how these movies always
work is like kiddo movies are like we
want to go photograph an indigenous
tribe or you know they're [ __ ] with
the rainforest and we gotta go out there
or we need to go do research and then
they kind of stumble across cannibals
except for except for Cannibal Holocaust
where it's like we're making a
documentary about these people I once
paid this cannibal to kill someone for
me
he even do it like a good job he just
like chop their head off and hate their
their eyes and I was like dude I paid
you $50 I hope this is cool cuz I I like
cannibalism as a genre it has its own
tone I gotta admit it looks like weight
shop looks kind of pretty you know oh
yeah Eli Roth always knows how to shoot
stuff so stuff some of those shots look
very almost GoPro ask which give it a
certainly realism because that's also
the Alaura of all the cannibal movies is
like it's kind of like found footage
where you're like whoa you know it's not
real or you'd hope Cannibal Holocaust
it's not real but at least some of that
it's the same thing of like these movies
thrive on that wonder of like oh what if
this is a real tribe because they've
used that before of like we stumbled
across a real tribe and this is what
happened and you know so they should be
annihilated all of them we legalized gay
marriage now we got to kill cannibals
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to this channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
we'd really appreciate it please do it
please please do it it is the girl from
not back well know nice and you can
check out I think it's Eli Roth's wife
what or girlfriend or hooker she's been
married Eli rather and you can check out
reasons to GRE on this plate on this
channel this channel with a playlist and
the as dank ass dubs channel playlist
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine where if we get more
followers we can get product placement
that's a good shot I want good Photoshop
I want to get a a shout out to Stephen
meek him he did a Meacham he said I
still want to see this happen you look
good on that chair buddy in regards to
this photo that he put oh yeah oh [ __ ]
Conan O'Brien is my favorite [ __ ]
like him and Louie CK just talked to two
comedians I love and as far as TV show
hosts go it's always been Conan O'Brien
IIE even had a saying in middle school
whenever I was down I would I would take
my cone zone medication yeah yeah
because he always says cone zone pets uh
cones dick why do you like pleased with
this hair but no I would love to go in
color and thanks Steven from earning
this photo together you're awesome